- Hey [inaudible].
This is Delta-1.
A wounded eagle needs
immediate cash and back.
Over.
(OVER RADIO) Roger that.
Inbound.
[spanish]
[automatic gunfire]
(OVER RADIO)
Delta-1, Raptor 6-6.
We are taking heavy fire.
We have to abort.
She promised you my
network, didn't she?
You know how the CIA works.
She promised me everything.
They lie all the time.
You know that.
But we can use it against her.
She is our asset.
We can feed her whatever
information we want.
I think I might have the
location of the [inaudible]..
We'll need to
get a visual first.
And one of our guys on the
ground to mark the target.
Raptor 6-6.
This is Delta-2.
My position is marked
by a VS-17 panel.
Target, seven meters.
(OVER RADIO) I have a visual.
You're inside our
margin of error.
I need approval, over.
[gunfire]
No!
Do it now!
(OVER RADIO) Raptor
2-2, going hot.
[explosions]
(OVER RADIO)
Target neutralized.
Delta-2, Delta-1, radio check.
The Prince is still
in that building.
We need a reaper
standing by ASAP.
Negative.
This is now a rescue mission.
You want a drone asset
to do your dirty work,
you call in your own.
Give me the phone.
[phone voice] 100 meters.
On target.
[screaming, gunfire]
Hey!
They're on my decks.
[gunfire]
Who's done now?
Let's move.
We're running out a tunnel.
[gunfire, grunt]
It's been a hell
of a ride, boys.
One mag left.
Make 'em count.
[shouting]
Target secure.
I'm sorry about Fish.
I think we got the Prince.
But I need to know for sure.
You or me, Gina.
Just like before, huh?
Gun to my head.
[gunfire]
[explosion]
Mother of god.
Fish is out of surgery.
He's alive, and he's tough,
and they got the best doctors
in land still working on him.
You guys did everything
you could, you understand?
What about Nasry?
(VOICEOVER) This is a
message to you, America.
You thought you could kill me.
Your Seals tried.
Your drones tried.
Your CIA tried.
But I am still here, because
you cannot kill an idea.
To Joe Graves, to Buddha Ortiz,
to the apostate Armin Khan,
I remember your faces.
I know your names.
You will pay for the death
of our martyred prince,
Tamerlin Shishoni.
I'm taking my own team, Bear.
OK.
If that's what you want.
[knocking]
I'll get it.
Lily.
(VOICEOVER) You
will never be safe.
[gunfire]
Where is he?
[gunfire, crying]
Get help.
Now.
[phone ringing]
[recording] Hey, it's Lena.
Leave a message.
You asked if we're
going to make it.
So I'm saying it now.
Yes.
Stay there.
We're gonna make it.
[inaudible]
I'm coming home.
I love you.
[music playing]